Although universities generate
billions of dollars with their athletic programs,
college athletes
are not paid, they only receive scholarships, and they
cannot earn money for
promoting products either, because of
rules implemented by the
National Collegiate Athletic Association, promotion of
blind people or college athletes.
They told Congress that less than
2% of them become
professional athletes and that the best chance
they have to earn money is
through product promotions
during their college careers. In addition,
the athletes say that many
universities ignore reports of
sexual abuse and  they also ignore injuries
to athletes in order to benefit and
maintain the good name of teams and
schools some states like my sister
and california have passed
state laws to protect athletes and
allow them to earn money and the
national collegiate athletic association
has also  im fiance  implement new rules
this
to allow athletes to earn
money through promotions but the
athletes want congress to pass
national rules and standards not
only about their pay but also about the
treatment and medical care that
college athletes receive reporting to
washington
alexandra lemon